if we want they develop machines with
general intelligence that surpasses ours
they would be in a very powerful
position hi this is Ryan Bailey for
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Professor philosophy at Oxford
University Nick Bostrom about his new
book super intelligence paths dangers
and strategies what's the book about
well it's about the potential for a
transition to machine intelligence era
we want to develop machines with general
intelligence that surpasses ours they
would be in a very powerful position so
how much smarter could these machines be
well the sky is the limit our kind of
fundamental constraints on information
processing in biological substrate so we
know human neurons are very slow
there is like a finite volume you can
have as your brain in maybe could make
it 10% larger but you couldn't have a
head the size of a warehouse these don't
apply to machine brains so in principle
they could radically surpass what the
biology can do well the analogy you use
in the book as I understand that we
would stand in relation to AI a eyes
artificial intelligences super
intelligences as we stand in relation to
the intelligence of worms or beetles is
something like that at some point the
concepts kind of begin to break down but
intuitively yeah does super intelligence
pose an existential risk to you manatee
and so an existential risk is one that
either settles to cause the extinction
of earth resonating intelligent life or
to permanently and drastically a destroy
our potential for desirable future
development but it looks if we think
about these rapid take off sonars we
have a super intelligence so far ahead
of everything else that you do be able
to shape the future according to its
will now if you start to think through
for most possible final goals that such
an artificial agent might have what
would be involved in maximal to realize
realizing one of those goals most of
them will tend to involve as a side
effect the destruction of the human
species and everything we care about it
as an example suppose you have an
his only goal is to make as many paper
clips as possible and maybe we built it
to run a paperclip factory so then if
you are a superintelligence and you try
to figure out how can I ensure that
there are as many paper clips as
possible in the future for first start
you would want to prevent anybody from
shutting you off because you can predict
if you get shut off there would be fewer
paper clips so right away if you could
eliminate humans that would increase
your level of safety since humans might
one day decide they don't like you so
now if you replace paper clip with
almost any other goal you could imagine
like most of them will have this sort of
consequence that that humans are not the
optimal way of realizing those calls
there might be a small subset very
special kinds of calls which in order to
maximally realize you would have to
preserve humanity like if the goal
actually involved our values in it then
you can't maximally realize our values
by just killing us all off probably
right so the big challenge then is to
reach into this huge space of possible
sort of mind designs our motivation
system designs and try to pick out one
of the very special ones that that would
be consistent with human survival and
flourishing and that's what you spend a
great deal of of the book dealing with
is what how is it that we you call it
the control problem I guess as far as
what it is so how do humans in a certain
sense maintain control of the
superintelligence so that it wants to
keep us around and benefit us so one is
capability control methods this would be
where you try to limit what the AI is
able to do and maybe put it in a box
disconnect Ethernet cable maybe only
allow it to communicate by typing text
on a screen and then some human
gatekeeper reads that and answers or
asks its question you restrict it's
capable call this an Oracle well there
would be one one yeah one one way of
trying to implement that and I think
those kinds of capability control
methods would be useful during the
developmental phase particularly I don't
think they are the ultimate answer to
this I think we will eventually need to
reach for a different kind of a solution
to the control method namely motivation
selection methods this is where
instead or in addition to trying to
limit what the system can do you try to
engineer it in such a way that it would
not want to cause harm you try to build
its motivation system so that it is some
sense either shares our values or has
some very limited motivation that that
would disincentivize it from from trying
to do things that we don't want more
generally how do we get to friendly and
beneficial superintelligence as I
discussed a number of specifics in the
book I think one thing that's kind of
obvious but worth emphasizing is to try
to accelerate work on the control
problem this is the problem of how you
would control super intolerant agent
there's very little resources going into
that in the world today maybe like half
a dozen people are working on that
full-time or that and that's only in the
last few years whereas there are tens of
thousands if not millions depending on
your definition who are working on
developing faster hardware our better
algorithms are developing like AI but we
got to get the control problem solved
before we solve the AI problem how to
build an AI that we want to solve both
of these problems but in the correct
order so looking at the horizon of
things what does the earliest time you
think that some sort of super
intelligent AI could be created and what
do you think is the likely amount of
time that would take it's not so far we
run a survey of experts in AI and asked
them by what year do you think there's a
50% chance that we will have human level
machine intelligence and the median
answer to that was 2040 or 2050
depending on exactly which group we
asked now there's a lot of uncertainty
around that so it could happen much
sooner or much later and we need to
think about the probability distribution
they smeared out over it could happen in
5 or 10 years it's very unlikely more
likely in a couple of decades I guess it
could take the rest of this century or
it could take longer and we just need to
live with the the uncertainty there and
sort of plan accordingly seems like it's
gonna be an interesting problem for the
rest of the century anyway thank you
very much Nick for coming by and talking
to us here at reason yeah thanks very
much good to see you
[Music]